[Musique]
tornio le petit village en plein milieu
du désert n'a jamais vu autant de
visiteurs c'est ici juste à côté du
poste frontalier que le gouvernement a
érigé la semaine dernière un camp de
tentes pour héberger jusqu'à 4000
enfants séparés de leurs parents
les images de ce centre de détention aux
allures de camp de réfugiés ont choqué
l'opinion publique partout dans le monde
il a décroché c'est un camp de
concentration moderne dit sandra une
dizaine d'étudiants universitaires sont
venus de plusieurs et a réclamé sa
fermeture
et cette colère sans précédent des
américains face aux abus infligés aux
réfugiés était le début d'un vrai
changement c'est ce que souhaite carlos
espina
trois sénateurs ont visité les
installations de tourny aujourd'hui
c'était la première délégation de
washington à y avoir accès ils nous
apprennent que le camp abrite pour
l'instant 250 jeunes des garçons
seulement âgés de 14 à 17 ans ils ont la
télé la climatisation accès à des
psychologues et à des prêtres de la
meilleure prison demeure une prison dit
il c'est un camp d'internement
les élus n'ont pas pu visiter les jeunes
dans leur tente
on leur a plutôt montré une vidéo
confidentialité oblige les sénateurs ont
été bouleversée de voir des jeunes qui
n'ont rien fait de mal traités comme des
prisonniers
you are one world is watching vous
n'êtes pas seuls dit sello enfants en
détention le monde entier vous regarde
et l'énergie de toute l'amérique est
désormais concentrée sur une mission
vous sortir de cette prison
une mission que les élus pourront
accomplir avec les passionnés de ces
étudiants qui jurent qu'ils ne lâcheront
pas le combat tant que les centres de
détention pour enfants ne seront pas
tous fermés ici sophie langlois
radio-canada a tourné au au texas